-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy-nominated,
Golden Globe-winning actress
you know from shows like
"Felicity" and "The Americans"
as well as the film
"Cocaine Bear."
-Whoo!
-Yeah.
she stars in "The Diplomat,"
which is streaming
now on Netflix.
Let's take a look.
-You can wait by that chair,
then you'll be out of eyeshot
when I open the door
to receive him.
Good.
-You always have cookies?
-Is that a problem?
-For a reprimand?
-Well, it's hardly
a reprimand, is it?
-Well, it should look like one.
-The tell isn't the biscuits.
It's the American ambassador
lurking in the corner.
-Please welcome back
to the show
our friend Keri Russell.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Welcome back.
-Thank you very much.
Thanks for having me.
-Congratulations on the show.
I feel like it's a show
everyone's talking about.
Everyone's talking
about "The Diplomat."
-Well, that's very nice.
-For years in "The Americans,"
you played someone conspiring
against the U.S. government.
Is it nice to now play a person
within the U.S. government?
-Well, I figured, you know,
I'm going to continue
living in the United States.
I better earn my keep.
-Yeah, exactly.
We were all starting to get
a little suspicious
about this Keri Russell
character.
-You know, you know.
We'll see. We'll see.
-You obviously shot this
in the U.K. and you shot
in a lot
of government buildings,
a lot of places where there were
a lot of protocols.
-A lot. Generally Americans
and British people
have different ways of working
in the world generally.
There's a lot of just
more words in a sentence
there tends to be, you know.
Americans are like,
"Yes, no," and British people
are just more polite
about everything.
And they ask about, you know,
the weather or your husband
or your pet
or whatever in this
very lovely way.
And Americans are like,
"No, this is what we're doing,
you know?"
But yes, we shot
in these incredible --
Like, we shot
at the U.S. embassy,
which was really incredible,
this state-of-the-art building.
They actually let us shoot
there, which is incredible.
I'm always like,
It's us and the crew guys.
Like, they're going to be
eating burritos.
Like, this is not --
Don't let us in here.
But they were very gracious,
and these big, beautiful --
I mean, that's sort of part
of the show is this thing
that Americans don't exactly
have this this grandeur
and this, you know,
those stately homes.
-Yeah. And I think like just
an appreciation
for the way things
are done a certain way.
Are you good
with rules like that?
Like, do they tell you before
you go to shoot in a building,
"Keri, you can't behave
the way you usually do"?
[ Laughter ]
-I definitely do not invite
"My mom's gone wild,"
that's for sure.
-You do have a pretty strong
group of moms gone wild.
-I have a strong group
of moms gone wild.
-There have been multiple
complaints in Brooklyn about
you and your friends.
-I would not be surprised.
I seriously would
not be surprised.
No, I am a rule follower.
In fact, on "Felicity,"
way back in the olden days...
[ Audience cheers ]
Thanks, guys.
Um, Speedman and Mandy --
-This is Scott Speedman.
-Scott Speedman.
-Let's give it up
for my friend Scott Speedman.
-Yeah, Speedy.
-Of course. Your brother.
Yes.
So we would, like, leave
for lunch and do something.
And I was the kid
who was always like, "Guys,
we have got to get back.
They are going to be worried and
we have 10 minutes to get back.
We have must be on time."
And they used to call me
the homework reminder.
-Really?
-Yeah.
-And now, you're a
very young person here.
And I'm assuming "Felicity" is
the first time
you did a talk show.
-Yes.
-Were you --
you were nervous, right?
-I'm a nervous person.
It's part of me.
-You do not give off
a nervous vibe.
-Sweating
uncontrollably right now.
-Gotcha.
[ Laughter ]
-So back then,
I was even more nervous
and I had never done
anything like that.
And there was no, like, social
media or any of that stuff.
-There was no preparation either
for being a talk show guest.
-No.
-Yeah.
-And it was lovely.
-Was it Rosie?
-Yes. Yes, thank you very much.
-It was Rosie,
and you know what else?
That means it was here.
It was in this studio.
This is Rosie's old studio.
So if you start having
flashbacks --
-I've wiped it out of my brain.
[ Laughter ]
So I was backstage
and she heard I was nervous.
And so she very -- she came back
and she said,
"Hey, you know,
we're going to go do this."
And I was like...
[ Breathing heavily ]
And I went out and she was being
so polite and so kind to me.
And you can actually see me.
I'm so nervous.
And I'm smiling. She's like,
"Where are you from?"
And I'm like, "Colorado,"
while wiping away a tear,
like tears coming down my face.
And everyone said,
"Oh, don't worry, no one will
notice, no one will notice."
And I went back and watched it.
I'm definitely crying.
[ Laughter ]
Definitely crying.
-Well, a lot of people cry
when they get asked,
"Where are you from?"
[ Laughter ]
-And you know what? It's like...
It's just part -- I hate
it less about myself.
And I think that's
what makes it easier.
I used to really
beat myself up about it,
and it's not normal having
to publicly speak or look --
-And it's a part of, I think,
acting that people forget.
And then again,
no one tells you, right?
You go, you maybe
study it as a craft,
you get a show
and then you forget
there's this whole promotional,
ceremonial aspect of it.
-There is. And they
are two very different --
Like, someone who's really good
at the ceremonial part
isn't necessarily great at
acting or, you know what I mean?
They don't always work together.
So yeah, which is very much
our show and that's...
-Yeah, you do a lot of ceremony
on "The Diplomat" as well.
You found a nice fit
for yourself.
-Yes, I did.
-You found another
nice fit on "The Americans" --
your partner, Matthew Rhys.
And I'm a big fan of his,
you know.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You know.
You know, I'm a big fan of his.
-Me, too.
-And the last time he was here,
we had a grand old time.
I want to make sure.
Was it Saint David's Day?
-Saint David's Day.
-Which is a big Welsh holiday.
-It's like the Welsh
St. Patrick's Day.
-Yes, Welsh St. Patrick's Day.
And one of the things you do is
there's a leek-eating contest.
You eat raw leeks.
And that's what me and --
Man, he's a...
[ Laughter ]
He's usually a sexy gentleman,
but when he's chomping
on a leek...
-He's going for it.
You know, I got the sense
that he was going to,
on St. David's Day,
maybe tie one on a little bit.
Like, he had that energy
when he was leaving here.
Is that your memory of it?
-We are, you know,
still parents,
so we're pretty boring
as it goes.
But every once
in a while he does.
And I will say
he did go out after that even,
after his time with you
and came home very late
and in a certain state.
And we actually, in the morning,
found the footage
of our security,
like the the security camera of
the front door and rewatched it.
-You and he together?
-Uh-huh.
-And was it -- How did he do?
Do you guys have stairs?
-We were like,
"Oh, oh, there you are.
You made it up the stairs.
Oh, going to find the key.
This might take a while."
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, he found it. Okay."
It was absolutely delightful.
-Obviously you guys
got to collaborate
on "The Americans."
You were both in --
First of all, congratulations on
"Cocaine Bear."
I mean, for real?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Whoa! Thanks.
-It was such an exciting thing.
-How crazy? So crazy.
-But it was an --
When you heard about it,
you were like,
"Oh, this is going to be fun."
And then it was deeply fun.
People were very excited
to see it.
Matthew was in "Cocaine Bear."
-He was.
-He did not last very long.
No spoiler -- That's a spoiler.
-No spoilers.
-But if you go to see
a lot of Matthew,
you're going to see a little.
-A little.
-Yeah.
-But he's going to go out
like a firecracker.
-He did. Yeah.
He made his time in "Cocaine
Bear" deeply worth it. Yeah.
-Stamp. Yeah.
-Now, have you stayed
in touch with the bear?
Yes. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
So when you shoot scenes
like this crazy movie...
-Yeah, this is a very --
I mean, this is all you
need for "Cocaine Bear."
-That's the movie.
-As a still for a film goes,
that's great.
-The suit. The hot pink suit
and the handbag.
Okay. Yeah.
So when you shoot those, like,
bear attacking scenes,
it's actually this really
lovely, you know,
Kiwi, New Zealand guy,
large man,
muscular, like, whatever,
dressed in a skintight unitard.
-Yeah.
-Crawling around
looking like a bear.
-Yeah.
-So maybe not always scary.
-Right.
-But strange. And then -- So
it's either him, lovely Allan,
climb-- you know,
doing his amazing movements
and you're kind of
watching or -- Banks
Elizabeth Banks yelling.
-Yeah.
-So that's like --
So I guess that's -- Yeah.
See now, that looks --
If I saw that in the woods,
that's scarier to me
than a bear.
-It is scary.
That is slightly scary.
But then otherwise it's Banks
yelling to you like,
"Oh, my gosh!"
You know, with a megaphone.
"His arm is being eaten off!
His leg's throwing!
There's blood everywhere! His
face is dripping with blood!"
And that's what
you're reacting to.
-I do have a third photo,
which is, I think, the scariest
of the options to see.
We have guy in bear suit.
We have weird half a bear
and then we just have
a solitary bear head.
Oh.
[ Laughter ]
There it is.
-This is what you're looking at.
You're like, "Oh, got it.
Scary.
It's very, very scary."
-Did you have -- I mean,
you're making the movie.
Did you have any sense
of the cultural impact
that it was going to have?
No, I genuinely mean,
like, you know, it's so hard
these days for a movie
to happen
where it's not based on,
you know, a Marvel film
or a Star Wars film
or some sort of, you know,
intellectual property.
And you guys were just like,
"Cocaine bear, let's go."
-We're going to go all in for
"Cocaine Bear." I love it.
The pandemic got weird.
What can I say?
-Yeah. People were like,
"Do we need another --
We should do another
Avengers movie."
And you're like, "Or should we
have a bear eat some cocaine?"
[ Laughter ]
-I guess I bet right.
-It was really great.
You did bet right.
I mean, Elizabeth Banks
did such a fantastic job.
-She did such a fantastic --
I'm so happy for her.
I mean, this is --
She's so awesome anyway,
but this is huge for her.
This is so great.
-That's great.
The new show is great.
And you as always are great.
Thanks so much
for being with us.
-Thank you.
-It's so great to see you.
Keri Russell, everybody.
"The Diplomat" is streaming
now on Netflix.
We'll be right back
with Graham Norton.